Okay, can you click play here?
Okay.
You can pause.
I can pause my performance?
Yeah, you can pause and you can talk.
Play and then pause the spacebar.
Okay.
Alright, this is where I locked in.
Every time someone says,
I need to lock in.
Before I start,
I already reviewed some of the stuff
that I need to fix,
such as my setups.
Especially inward block,
I focus on my
90 degree angle for my setups
before I even start.
Nice.
Right here I was a little bit shaky.
I was pretty nervous.
Oh, that was my,
that was the best part of my pattern.
I think my front snap kick
was pretty good.
Nice.
Setup good.
Okay,
not that bad.
I just want
some key moments.
Do you want to watch a video
explaining how you're being scored?
You know this already.
I think I should know.
Can I just watch some of it?
Yeah.
I just want to watch one part.
With this one,
if you're a color belt,
your average,
where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually from a
1.1.
So,
with this one,
as I was saying, it's a total of
10.
So, let's see.
Are you scoring?
Yeah, I think I got it.
Okay, so we're going to practice reading.
Okay.
So, minor errors.
Real time, we cannot pause this time.
So I'm going to watch?
Yes, you're going to watch, and then you're going to be
a judge.
We cannot pause, because that's how the real thing works.
And then major errors.
And then right after the performance,
into the power
and speed, coordination of rhythm,
expression of energy.
Good.
We're just waiting for it.
Okay.
It's still pausing, so you can relax.
It takes a little bit of time to talk.
I'm going to wait for it to stop.
All right, guys.
So,
I'm going to shoot okay?
One, two, three.
And I'll stop recording.
Okay.
So,
I'm going to look at the
devices
for you.
Okay.
Well,
Thank you.